you know what really makes my ass itch
as women age especially after having children
they are expected to bounce back
they are expected to be the most perfect
Polish plucked and Pilate version of themselves
oh wow
it's totally socially accepted and sometimes even admired
for men to grow into a potato
so while we decided that it was a moral failing of a 38 year old woman
who popped out three kids
to no longer fit into her jeans from when she was 25
we're being told it's because we just don't prioritize our health
we're letting ourselves go
when that's exactly what motherhood is
by design it is letting go of your needs as a woman
as an individual as a human being
in service to your husband and children
or at least that's the propaganda that they're trying to get you to believe
a good wife a good mother
gives up all self autonomy
all selfish notions of personal identity and care
for the betterment offer children and family
but then what do they do they complain that she let herself go
there she goes she didn't let herself go anywhere
and we blame the woman
because it's so much easier to put that on personal accountability right
it's so much easier to say hmm
she just doesn't care enough
she just doesn't care enough to be sexy for her husband
and then when he leaves
we justify it as a collective society
we will buy into the excuse of oh
I just wasn't attracted to her anymore
or she was too tired for sex all the time
she didn't have enough time for me
you know one of the tells
not the only one but one of the tells
I can tell that somebody has a good husband
they look good they feel good
because they have time because where do you think that time is coming from